what okay guys I like the left one
maximum out and took a bunch of photos
that Angelica and I have not seen yet
yep and today we're gonna see if the new
nothing phone 2 can beat out the iPhone
14 plus and the pixel 7 Pro while
costing a lot less money so here is the
first photo in the street oh my goodness
look at that right one it's all blown up
blown out where's all the clouds yeah
I'm slightly thrown off by the colors in
the middle one I feel like they're a
little too purple but other than that I
do like the detail I like that the hair
and the tree is not crushed like on the
left one so I'm going with the center
and I like the left it looks so much
better with those glowing highlights
that's what I like it really stands out
to me and before I reveal them grab a
piece of paper and a pen or your notepad
you can vote along with Angelic and
redeem we have 35 photos we'll see which
phone is the best and the nothing phone
did the worst we'll see if this trend
continues especially in the nighttime
photos but for now here is the next shot
the first thing I noticed is that the
one on the left the contrast is way too
much for me and the saturation is way
too much it looks very unrealistic I
think the center one looks the most
natural I kind of like the left one
again I don't know I like how it's
bright the truck in the back is all nice
brought up yeah and this is like a
contrast uh kind of HDR comparison so
nothing good Vadim got a nothing very
contrasty there and this is the first
selfie here with mixed lighting once
again I'm going for the left the left
one looks really really good I like the
Highlight roll off on the face as you
can see the one in the center her face
is completely flat like not much
shadowing there I don't like the left I
like the one on the right are you guys
going to agree with this video ever
we'll see
okay left and right oh I found a pixel
wow guys I like the left one you keep
choosing the left I'm just kidding it's
the center so this is uh a zoom shot
right here I believe this is 30X Zoom
you'll see right here what there you go
so the pixel has a way better Sim camera
so this is the most Zoom shot I did but
here you can't read anything if you need
to take a picture of a sign somebody's
license plate good luck
and we have our portrait shot
this lady made this by hand all right
okay it's definitely not the one on the
right it's not able to focus on the
entire subject just a small portion of
it yeah and between the the left and the
center I'm really liking the contrast in
the center one I feel like it really
pops yep I agree I like the center as
well I really don't like how this is all
so flat and gray it's kind of Blended
out to the back you guys show us the
nothing that extra contrast really helps
there and here we have a portrait of My
Wife and Kids is the left one a portrait
and that that's yeah
it didn't work so the left one I took
three or four times whereas the others
added to take it once the file is named
portrait
but it's not a portrait I mean I'm gonna
have to go with the center even though
it looks like it has a little bit too
much blur it actually makes them stand
out a lot more for me I'm not a big fan
of the center one the blur is too much
and it's very distracting the one on the
right looks very very natural I'm gonna
go for that okay so no love for the left
and we have a nothing and nothing
iPhones winning what knife yeah that's
for me not for me and here we have an
ultra wide okay the left one is garbage
right away look at that trash yeah I
really like that the center all of the
the brights and the highlights and the
clouds and he's really pops right here
where he kind of doesn't feel like the
subject on the right one yeah I do like
the center as well looks a little bit
too like off in terms of colors and
stuff yeah it's flat and dark Center
looks good looks really good and the
iPhone 4. nothing is actually the only
one with the 50 megapixel compared to
two 12 megapixel Ultra wides here I
don't know what happened there
here we have a portrait shot indoors
okay wow wow I don't like the two on the
right they're just so blue and cool I'm
going a little dark too with the details
and like the hair yeah the left one like
look at that napkin it's white it's not
blue yeah I also really like that this
foreground is like blurred out and he's
like really the main subject as opposed
to those cool and you guys voted for the
iPhone with that portrait interesting
but before we move on I want to show you
guys our little cabin at my family's
seasonal camping grounds which now
finally has AC thanks to Mr Cool who
sponsored this video this is their 4th
gen DIY mini split heat pump air
conditioner that does both cooling and
heating and it was so easy to set up
that we did it ourselves in these five
easy steps first we use the included
template to drill holes for the indoor
unit bracket as well as the outside Port
then route the line set through the port
and mount the indoor unit on the outside
route the lines to the outdoor unit and
connect the fully pre-charged ac lines
as well as the power to the outdoor unit
and Bam we now have a life-saving AC
unit for those hot summer nights and we
did it all ourselves so if this is
something you'd love to set up yourself
including multi-zone units use the links
down below to order one today and here
is a very yellow shot yeah right away
the center one just looks like it's
blown out here and it's smeared I really
like the colors on the right one like
she's glowing here where she looks a
little dull and flat on the left one the
right one looks great I think I also
agree I'm noticing more detail on the
right like you can see in the floors
more sharpness for sure all right and
that is the iPhone which definitely was
the most true to life and here we have
another shot a lot of detail here and
the interesting thing is one of these
cameras has 12 megapixels while the
other two have 50 for the main I
immediately like the colors in the
center everything is bright everything
pops the other two look really gray and
blue yeah the center one is definitely
the best the one on the right is way too
cool and this one like the detail is
just gone it's not as detailed as the
others you guys voted for the iPhone
that has the white balance just spot on
oh this is a food shot okay I'm hungry
blown out too much contrast I mean if I
was gonna eat one of these it would be
the left yeah I'm thinking
right I'm I'm seeing so much like
texture detail on that one and we have
no love for the nothing shot interesting
here we have a tough shot oh gosh that
right one looks terrible yeah your face
just lost all the Shadows what do you
mean I look like that I don't have any
contrast on my face that's insanity this
is hard because the camera software has
to be really good because you have a
black wall with bright light white uh
dress I'm really liking the center you
can see all the detail in the dress
everything on the wall where the left
one just kind of got flushed and yeah
this one is also flat and a little bit
too brought up uh the center one looks
awesome and we have a pixel shot nice
detail and great natural colors
and here we have a macro shot you want
to get a close-up of some nice tiny
little flowers it has to be the left one
immediately you can see every teeny tiny
little thing
the center one you can see everything in
the back which I don't like I personally
don't like the left now I feel like it's
way too bright and like super warm I
kind of want to go with the center if I
look super close I could see more detail
okay and
here is the original shot now the pixel
has a really close macro mode that works
great that's why there's no blur because
it's the ultralight switching over
whereas other ones I had to crop and I
took these many times to make sure the
photos are accurate
now we have the sunset okay portrait
with flaring these shots can turn out
really beautiful there's there's things
to like and dislike about each of these
and a lot of difference huh I really
like the moodiness in the sun of the
left one you can actually see it but her
face really gets kind of like covered
and washed out and Yeah dark too the
right one just doesn't look that great
altogether but the center one's pretty
blown out I don't know as a photographer
that has done a lot of portraits and
weddings I know which one I would choose
but you guys choose I'm gonna choose the
center because I like the best even
though it's blown out in the highlights
um her face and hair you could see more
detail and it's not as distracting and
there's a lot of glow yeah
guys shows the iPhone yes as a
photographer for this kind of shot we
wouldn't care about the sun being there
we want that subject that looks better
whoa now we have this building here okay
well as I mentioned two of these phones
have 50 megapixel and one is a 12.
definitely the right one yeah for sure
me too the right one lots of detail you
could actually read a Vista Pavilion and
then what do you think between these two
how much of a difference is there oh
they're very close they're extremely
close all right so both of you guys
voted for the right and that is the
nothing phone so good job both the pixel
and nothing have 50 megapixel but the
pixel doesn't give you a mode to shoot
in 50. oh it always down samples oh what
so out of these 35 photos I think we
have like about five Zoom shots and my
kids love shots like this they always
want me to zoom in capture them playing
Center one for sure I mean yeah and I
think we know which one that is it is
the pixel whereas the other ones not so
good we have this Sunset shot with the
beautiful mountains layers of depth here
wow I mean I'd go with the center I have
to go I like the colors the glow if you
look really closely you actually see
details here where the left one is a
bunch of garbage terrible but yeah
definitely Center yeah for this kind of
shot it looks great here the building is
like bright it really destroyed the
whole Sunset that is the iPhone right
there
here we have another one another one of
the zoom shots Center yeah center now my
wife is actually trying to take a
picture of this concert that was going
on we were standing outside of the fence
because we didn't pay
so here are the originals the pixel does
such a good job the other two cannot
zoom very far now we have this okay
evening shot of my kids I really wanted
a picture on this thing I like the
setter it has to be the center yeah it's
nice and bright brought up but it also
has contrast whereas this one kind of
washed everything out and the other
one's kind of dimmed yeah they're kind
of gray yeah the white balance here is
spot on in the sky you also have those
things and that is the iPhone again does
a great job in these situations
now my daughter really wanted a picture
in this Forest area that was Moody
I'm going with the right right I like it
if you look close there's lots of detail
it's got the white balance looking
really good Center one's really flat the
left one you can see it's kind of like
pasty and missing some details yeah the
left one looks kind of dull but the
center one there's so much like blown
out and like just detail missing on them
and we got another one for the iPhone
that maintained that Sunset look here we
have this beautiful
water I immediately want to go for the
center me too immediately I really love
this gradient you see the sunset going
to the blue where this is all just kind
of dull and this one is dark the iPhone
I did not know when you're taking these
pictures you can't see as much on the
screen until you lay them out like this
whoa
okay left one is out instantly does not
look good it's the center yeah Center
again yeah it looks the most detailed
for sure we have all this layering here
that is the pixel and this was not too
zoomed in either here we have this
dessert that we got for the kids with
the dark in the background there's
something about the left and the right
ones that I just don't like I don't know
the left one the subject just doesn't
really stand out everything just kind of
gets clumped together
um I really like the brights of the
center one I think I'm gonna go for
Center yep me too I really like this
Center because uh all the details are by
far the most sharp and you have the nice
glow yeah
and this is actually getting into night
mode already it was a lot darker than
these pictures show and this one has a
lot of differences definitely a tough
shot to do I think I'm going with the
left Center no yeah
um the one on the right just like the
subject she's she's kind of blurry she's
almost almost out of focus like in his
legs it is Miss focused it is yeah yeah
I didn't know that until I put them side
by side I think the left one looks the
most
realistic and
the middle one obviously obviously
so dark you can't even see her I'm going
with the right I feel like this is just
smudged a little bit everywhere all the
details
you guys let me know what you think down
in the comments who do you agree with
here and it's blown out eyes crushed
pixels so that nothing just did not
focus on nothing I didn't expose or
nothing focused on the background yeah
we have an ultra wide here center it's
getting really dark here instantly the
center that looks so yeah this looks bad
that looks garbage the left one you
can't even tell that they're there they
just have part of the tree
pixel with that ultra bike great nothing
once again too dark yeah
and this was an ice sculpture okay
that's cool somebody made that's really
cool I don't know something the the left
one looks so good to me it looks dark
but like these lights don't look blown
out it looks very moody it looks very
sharp the left one stands out for me
personally I like the center I feel like
the ice just looks so like delicious so
no love for the right side here
I got it with that thing and a 14 so
nothing's starting to do a little better
here we have a nighttime selfie this is
tough because all of them have their
issues they all have their issues
the color
the right one is so fun and what is this
on my face I actually had to retake this
photo because I thought there's some
extra layering can I choose
yeah none of these look great
because this one is way too flat yeah
the left is the least bad
the pixel again man yep and we have this
clock tower
that is the right for me yeah the center
is horrible
and you could actually see the little
time yeah the right one in the car yeah
this one looks shockingly good yeah it's
really cool and it's a pixel and this is
not crazy zooms all of the detail right
here is so impressive I have this night
shot okay now it was dark I will tell
you it was dark and they wanted to climb
on here I mean if I'm trying to share
this on social media it's probably gonna
be the left it doesn't look great but it
yeah it looks better yes I guess yeah
the iPhone over here and the interesting
thing is this was a one second exposure
this was a two second automatically wow
and this was a six second on the pixel
wow crazy oh wow you're not going to
want to wait that long with your kids
there no you won't yeah my kids are
trained already stay still but we have
this beautiful sunset when we had a tiny
bit of light left I I immediately want
to go
artifact
it's very smudgy and you've lost a lot
of detail over here yeah I agree I'm
going with the left I especially don't
like how like some orange and swampy
this looks yeah I like how they kept it
more neutral yeah
that was the pixel and here we have a
Moody Park scene it was very actually I
won't say say much you guys should tell
me what you guys like I'm going to the
center I I want to say the left this
just looks so bad to me yeah the right
one for sure looks bad Center I feel
like is the most balanced with detail
issue the thing I don't like about the
left is that everything's yellow this is
yellow the road is yellow the grass is
you know orange it is more yellow maybe
I should this actually has differences I
see a lot more detail in here and this
just looks so bad to me I'd rather have
the left so you guys already voted I
will say that in reality it was even
more yellow than this really yeah
pixel
we have a portrait Street Scene whatever
it is so bad this is terrible look right
behind her is like insanity insanely
blur which is so fake and I will say
that's a default setting because you can
tweak this kind of stuff most people
keep it in default the default is bad I
mean the center is killer though because
it's got a really smooth the range of
blur and she's the most detailed her
hair is not crushed like this one Center
one and I don't know if you guys noticed
the portrait did not work because it
doesn't look like it worked and I took
this shot six or seven times wow it says
that portrait works when you take the
picture you think the portrait worked so
the range on this phone is terrible
here are the results
so that nothing over blurs everything
yeah makes it look like it's nothing
back there and the pixel is just
unreliable
and you don't have much range at all
here we have this neon sign that was
beautiful in reality imma go with the
center yeah
the center because of the left it's
really blurry all these little uh words
here is really blurry this has a nice
glue I decided what it pops and I like
how it has some light onto the flowers
they're beautiful I want to see it's
cool
and that was the most true to life both
the sign the flowers and everything here
that's cool high contrast dragon and a
night scene I like the left man this
thing is sharp as heck if you look at
all the details floor texture super
sharp the colors are nice and natural
and it doesn't blow out some of the
white areas that looks nice for me the
the right one stood out for a photo like
this where there's colors I really
appreciate what the right one did no
love for the center
and then the last shot
okay it's not the right one Center
that's for me Center look at that yeah
the left one is just too smudgy yeah
artifacts here this one looks really
natural and you got a lot of detail here
as well and this Stars this is the only
one on a tripod set up yeah there's
something we literally see that and of
course that is the pixel because it has
astrophotography mode the other ones I
took the longest exposures that they
could
but it does not match up so now guys go
ahead if you voted along with us count
up your results comment it down below
and let's see how the new 600 nothing
compares to the iPhone and the pixel
which I believe the msrps are the same
uh
buddy you want to go first
yeah well I mean I'm sorry but the
nothing has nothing on the other phone I
got five for the nothing 14 for the
iPhone and 16 for the pixel very close
yeah I got
um paper yeah
ate the iPhone 13 for the pixel so
pretty close but then four for the
nothing
yeah I mean like all the night modes
were just so bad
so dark all the portraits and the
portraits also suffered almost
everything was kind of yeah now I will
add
um this has two new 50 megapixels in the
back a new 30 in the front and with the
original nothing phone when we first
tested it out it also did really bad
pretty much similar results after about
half a year they tweaked the software it
made it better and I also updated all
the software on all of these phones
before I took these pictures now the
pixel did great in Zoom shots oh yeah oh
yeah oh but if if you don't care about
Zoom I think the iPhone's the best
all-around and the nothing phone
it's just not that great at least for
now so let us know your thoughts down in
the comment section below click that
Circle above to subscribe and you have
not yet seen our comparison of the
iPhone and the nothing phone check it
out right over there it's very
interesting and we will see you guys in
the next video
[Music]